>> Dana: WILLIAM LA JEUNESSE,
THANK YOU.
>> Bill: BORDER PATROL AGENTS
RECENTLY CAPTURED MORE THAN 100
PEOPLE IN SEVERAL SMUGGLING
ATTEMPTS.
IN LAREDO TEXAS ON THE BORDER.
THE CITY IS WAITING FOR FEMA TO
ARRIVE AND HELP OUT.
TEXAS MAYOR PETE SAENZ IN
LAREDO.
IT CAUGHT MY EYE.
YOU HAD A TRACTOR TRAILER
PULLED OVER, 44 PEOPLE INSIDE.
A COMMERCIAL TANKER, 43 PEOPLE
INSIDE.
ANOTHER TRACTOR TRAILER MARCH
9, 24 PEOPLE INSIDE.
WHAT ARE YOU UP AGAINST, MAYOR?
>> EXACTLY THAT.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME THIS
MORNING BILL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
JUST A BRIEF DESCRIPTION.
LAREDO IS 160 MILES UPRIVERS
FROM BROWNSVILLE AND 600 MILES
DOWN RIVER FROM EL PASO SO
PEOPLE KNOW.
LAND PORT IN THE ENTIRE WESTERN
HEMISPHERE.
YES, WE’VE BEEN -- EACH REGION.
LAREDO SECTION IS DIFFERENT
FROM THE EL PASO AND DEL RIO.
WE EXPERIENCE MORE SINGLE
ADULTS FROM LAST YEAR COMPARED
TO THIS YEAR, THERE HAS BEEN
ABOUT 140% INCREASE.
THAT’S SUBSTANTIAL.
AND 90% OF THEM ARE SINGLE MALE
ADULTS PRIMARILY FROM MEXICO.
OF COURSE, THESE FOLKS THEN
THROUGH THE CARTELS OR THE
CRIMINAL ACTIVITY THAT WE HAVE
IN THE BORDER AREA ON THE
MEXICAN SIDE AND OVERFLOWS TO A
CERTAIN EXTENT ONTO OUR SIDE.
ALTHOUGH OUR CITIES ARE SAFE
BUT YET MATTERS OF THIS CALIBER
DO OCCUR.
THEY END UP IN STASH HOUSES.
FROM THE STASH HOUSES THEY END
UP BOARDING THESE TRACTOR
TRAILERS OR THESE VANS.
WE HAVE HAD A SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE CLOSE TO 4,000 ARRESTS
-- 2,000 ARRESTS IN STASH
HOUSES AND I WOULD SAY ABOUT
CLOSE TO THAT AMOUNT ALSO ON
THESE VANS AND TRACTOR TRAILERS.
AS A MAYOR THAT CONCERNS ME.
OBVIOUSLY THERE IS THE
POTENTIAL OF THINGS ESCALATING
AND MORE OVERFLOW.
I’M GLAD THE BORDER PATROL IS
HERE AND FEDERAL AGENCIES.
>> Bill: THEY HAVE TO DO
SOMETHING.
AHEAD OF HOMELAND SECURITY THEY
SAID THE BORDER IS SECURE AND
THE BORDER IS CLOSED.
IS IT SECURE AND CLOSED, MAYOR?
>> NO, TO BOTH THOSE QUESTIONS.
I HEARD THAT YESTERDAY FROM
BOTH PRESIDENT BIDEN AND ALSO
FROM SECRETARY MAYORKAS.
THESE ARE GOOD WORDS AND I
APPRECIATE THAT VERY MUCH BUT
WORDS NEED TO BE FOLLOWED BY
ACTIONS.
WE HAVEN’T SEEN ACTIONS YET.
DOES IT MEAN THAT THESE UAC’S
UNACCOMPANIED AND FAMILIES
TURNED AWAY TO CONTINUE USING
TITLE 42?
IF NOT, THEN THOSE WORDS ARE
MEANINGLESS.
SO WHAT DO WE DO?
HONESTLY, I THINK THERE IS A
PLAN TO AMEND THE ASYLUM LAWS.
SO PEOPLE CAN APPLY FROM THEIR
COUNTRIES OF ORIGIN.
THAT WOULD BE GREAT.
THE POINT HERE BEING IS THAT WE
NEED TO PREVENT THIS JOURNEY
FROM THOSE COUNTRIES TO THE
BORDER.
IT IS LESS RISK, LIFE AND LIMB
AND MONEY AND SO ON TO THESE
FOLKS BUT ALSO HERE IN THE
COMMUNITY.
WE’RE THE FIRST RESPONDERS.
THEY NEED TO BE COGNIZANT OF
THAT.
WE NEED THIS THING REMEDIED
QUICKLY.
>> Bill: THANK YOU, MAYOR, PETE